[Music]
what's going on guys this is Rob and
welcome back to another episode of the
rundown where I'm just like here is a
story that I read somewhere and this
story is amazing and you guys should
check it out too and so in this video we
are going to be talking about the
fantastic for meeting God now this is a
huge discussion for a lot of comic fans
largely because a lot of them don't know
what they're talking about they said we
just read online somewhere that God is
Jack Kirby and they take it as absolute
truth because it's the Internet but this
story will actually tell you that it is
Jack Kirby but God could also be Stan
Lee the difference on what you wanted to
be since they both created Marvel
characters anyway so in the Fantastic
Four and by 1999 I think is when the
story was written italic number there
were a lot of different things going on
not very many of them were good but like
Susan storm had Valeria Richards and dr.
doom was like hey I want to be Godfather
to this child and reads like I don't
know man you're kind of a bad guy and
dr. Doom's like we know what I'm gonna
scar your face there take that now there
was also a story where Doctor Doom was
dealing with bad guys stuff doing bad
guy stuff I remember what it is but
anyway he ended up getting into a battle
with the Fantastic Four and started
jumping from one host body to the next
those coming book fans they care enough
about the Fantastic Four feel free to
correct me on that if you want to the
Fantastic Four don't matter enough to me
outside of Jonathan Hickman's run but by
Doctor Doom ends up jumping from one
host body to the next and it involves
like Nick Fury and shield and those guys
United Nations so on and so forth anyway
eventually it gets down to the point
where he takes possession of Ben Grimm
because Ben Grimm is nine unstoppable
with the exception of like Thor and The
Incredible Hulk maybe blue Marvel in the
century it really kind of depends on
who's writing the story at the time and
so Reed Richards is like there's only
one thing I can do to defeat my friend I
have to kill him and so he shoots Ben
Grimm with like this giant laser thing
which inadvertently kills Ben Grimm he
thought you would just make dr. D leave
but Ben Grimm is now dead and Reed
Richards spent like an hour trying to
bring him back to life he couldn't do it
and so then
start sitting around trying to figure
out ways to revive Ben Grimm and then
come to the realization that Ben Grimm's
body is alive his soul is just gone
whatever hashtag comic logic so Reed
Richards is like hey I have an idea on
how to get Ben Hur back and the rest of
the Fantastic Four are like well how do
we how do we do that he was like we'll
just go to heaven and we'll ask God to
give him back so we could put his soul
back into his body and so Susan storm
and Johnny Storm are like whatever man
we've seen crazier stuff before we once
saw a man put on a glove and wipe out
half life in the universe with some
shiny precious jewels
whatever man we will we'll see what
happens with this and so they jump into
what looks like a time travel device
it's not really less'n jump the
dimensions and they jump to the
dimension of God now when they get there
there's like demons and stuff that are
attacking them and like I guess they're
angels I don't know they're like
attacking the Fantastic Four and they've
got like words on their faces that are
like you're not supposed to be here
whatever anyway then Grimm's soul is
with the soul of his older brother who
had long since been dead and apparently
Ben Graham's older brother taught him
integrity I don't know whatever and so
his older brothers like hey look man
like your friends are not supposed to be
here we're basically going to run them
off if they do not leave them they will
have to deal with the maker and so Ben
Grimm is like alright well I mean I
guess head size but let's keep on going
so they keep on walking they keep on
going the Fantastic Four continuing on
their journey eventually they catch up
with Ben Grimm and Ben Graham's brother
is like hey look guys you're not
supposed to be here you know and they're
like yeah like Ben Grimm is part of the
family man and he can't just break up a
family like that you know we want to
tell God that he's wrong and we want to
bring Ben Grimm soul back to his body so
we can just hang out and then comes
brother is like alright I mean if you
guys want to do that you can but you
guys should just stay here like if you
guys stay here you'll have access to
like infinite knowledge on everything
and we could even bring your kids and
all that kind of stuff and so Reed's
like ah he thinks about a four-second
he's like no nah man we're not going to
do that like we are going to hang out
here at home
we just want to take Ben Grimm back and
so Ben Grimm's brother is like okay so
they get to the pearly gates they get to
get to like the gates of heaven are
these suppose we let the pearly gates
you know and they get there and it's not
pearly gates it's like an amalgamation
of all the technology that Reed Richards
is ever invented to keep stuff safe and
so Reed's like well this is weird like
it's all my stuff like is it me like oh
my god and it's like no Reid you are not
God you're just some guy with white and
brown hair that can stretch you are not
God you literally got killed by Deadpool
with a gun so weird like okay well let's
let's figure out what this is they go
through and they start solving the log
they start getting all that stuff sorted
out alright and once they actually get
inside they go through like this weird
you know kind of dimensional thing where
there's like stars and planets and stuff
you know it's whatever like you would
expect the journey to heaven look like I
have no real idea but as they're
circling through like real cogs and
stuff they eventually open the door
which is like sitting on the truck and
so like is everybody ready to go in is
anybody ready to go meet God and the
Fantastic Four like yeah let's go meet
God and so once I get in there like it's
this like it's an office and like Jack
like like Jack Kirby's just drawing
stuff and he's like are you guys gonna
come in here and the Fantastic Four were
like it anybody expect this and they're
like well no of course we did not read
we have never been to heaven before we
have never seen God we did not know what
to expect because we've never done this
before and so like they get in there and
you know they're there like asking
stupid questions
Johnny storms making dumb jokes like
where are your elves whatever man and so
they're talking to like Jack Kirby and
he's like so what's what's up like what
did you guys come here for you know even
though he's one of the whole and you
should know everything but he's like
what's up looks like what's going on
guys and they're like well we just want
like the soul of Ben Grimm and we want
to take him home so that he can be in
his body and he can be stuck in his
stone form and be miserable for the rest
of his life and so the one above all is
like man I don't know about that but so
like Reed looks down on what it is he's
doing and he's just like drawing some
he's like drawing universes by drawing
everything in comics and so Reed's like
oh yeah like I guess you do that that's
how you create stuff and Jack Kirby's
like yeah man that's
I do things you know I create stuff and
then the credit gets stolen from you so
he's like I'm gonna fix your face so he
fixes the face of Reed Richards gets rid
of his scars makes his face back to
normal and Susan storms like yeah you're
pretty again and so he's like yes man
you guys can have Ben Graham you guys
can take Ben Grimm spirit back with you
to earth because I'm the one above all
and I got bigger fish to fry gana my
office and so they're like this is more
like get off my lawn but like there
they're like okay cool a man like we
really appreciate you getting the soul
back - you know Ben Grimm and he's back
in his regular form now like one but
walls like drawing his human form and so
then Grimm's like yeah I get to go back
home and be miserable because I'm stuck
in my stone form and I can't be a
regular person again you guys literally
took me from paradise from the happiest
place in existence and brought me back
to earth where bad things happen all the
time
thanks I guess and so that's that's the
end that's the end of the story oh by
the way the one above all drew a picture
of the Fantastic Four cool I guess Susan
storm looks a little old and fat
whatever but anyway I hope you guys
enjoyed this let me know you guys think
drop a like if you guys dug it make sure
you hit the subscribe button to become
part of the Rob core and I will catch
you guys later peace
[Music]
you